and I believe we're good to go
good afternoon it's good to see you all
still around
I was already expecting like we're
getting close to the end and I see
people with suitcases passing by
thinking like oh they're leaving they're
missing out on this talk but I'm happy
to see you here
today this is our next hour is going to
be all about webassembling combination
without net I want to emphasize
um it's a lot webassembly security as
well so it's not only.net
um just the residents who in this room
works with.net on a daily basis I think
most of the other side yes you're the
Right audience so we're going to talk
about technology Stacks that you can use
on webassembly but that can literally be
everything right but I'm gonna get that
once we're going to do some demos and
work through all the stuff so that's
cool okay cool
um using webassembly to run extend
secure your.net application first who am
I
introductionary slide with a big picture
so my name is Neil Stanis and I work as
a security researcher for vericoat I
have a background.net development which
I've done for like over a decade and I
moved into the security space where I
did security consultancy some ethical I
can pen testing and right now I'm
combining all of that in my role at very
code so you probably know the very good
aesthetic analysis and if you're doing
stuff with.net and very code then you
should talk to me because that's what I
do as well I'm not going to talk about
vertical anymore if you want to talk
more about us then come see me
afterwards because today's subject will
be webassembly right
and if you go to webassembly.org and if
you check out the first let's say high
level goals you'll see that it's a
portable binary format that will serve
as a compilation Target that can
literally run everywhere it's also high
performance
should be really secure by default so
when this was introduced I think there
was 2017 when webassembly was a 1.0 or
something that everybody calls MVP it
was released for all major browsers so
you can run webassembly inside your
browser
I think the first glimpses of
webassembly itself was 2015 the people
from Mozilla Firefox started out some of
the bits and pieces and it of course
originated from some other web
components which I'm not going to spend
too much time on but webassembly itself
what happened after this was done
existing code basis were compiled to
webassembly right so if you take a Seco
base and if you take a tool called M
scripting which you're going to see in a
bit as well you can compile it into
webassembly and AutoCAD has got a
version of their tool I've not run it
I've actually need this just a
screenshot I took from the internet of
course but it allows you to run their
software inside the browser right so
webassembly there might even be somebody
from AutoCAD on this conference I did
see it on some of the batches so maybe
they can explain a bit more how it works
but this was a nice thing right Adobe
did the same with some of their products
and it's all based on AMP scripting
compiling your C code into webassembly
and run it
that was the first thing what happened
after that what's what's what else did
we see
so webassembly was also used as an SDK
for sdks so both Disney plus and Amazon
have got two really nice blog posts
where they explain how to use
webassembly side note if I'm referring
to articles all of the links are in the
notes and at the end you will see a get
a repo that will have a node version of
the slides and you can find all the
links inside of that
but the nice thing is that they
explained because you can run near
native you can literally run on a lot of
devices they build up their application
and also high performance if you're
streaming media right you can if you
compile it into webassembly module it
can really be done easily
um both Disney plus and Amazon do it and
Amazon Prime even allows to be like
targeting 8 000 devices all at once
which is I think nice even the mobile
stuff they reuse it but you can imagine
like even if you have Android TV or
apple or you have some kind of setup box
you got from the cable provider
um they all have that client inside
right and it works and it's all and a
lot of that it's done because of
webassembly so I think this is pretty
cool technology gets everywhere and the
nice thing is because it's a compilation
Target you can write
in a lot of languages you compile that
to webassembly which you're going to see
in a bit but you can do go you can do
python you can do Java right now as well
I've seen some stuff from kotlin over
the last couple of days so it's it's all
getting there and it's all running on
webassembly which I think is pretty cool
so this technology evolved
and
I'm going to take a step back a bit and
I want first to dig into some of the
security aspects for what makes
webassembly secure because there are
certain things inside the language or
like the way it works that we need to be
aware of
then we're going to run.net on
webassembly which you probably can
already imagine what that will be but
we're going to look into some of its
internals how it works because we need
to have some understanding
and we're going to do it browser-based
but we're also going to of course pull
it outside of the browser and that's
where the fun stuff happens then we're
going to take that concept and we're
going to extend.net webassembly so have
existing webassembly modules executed
inside that context and then also focus
more on security aspects of it because
there's a really rich layer of security
on top of it and we can leverage that
and we can take care of some security
problems that we face at the end it's
going to be concluded in Q a as I said
so webassembly if you look up the design
they had the goals of be fast efficient
and portable right so near native speed
across different platforms that was the
exact reason what we saw with Amazon and
with Disney plus readable and debuggable
so you have a byte code you can open it
up you can look into it but there's also
textual representation
and I'm going to show you that how it
looks it's it's not it's like readable
you can easily see like hey this is
where the problem is no but you can read
it if you want to
it wants to be secure keep secure
because it's run inside of a Sandbox
environment so running inside of a
browser same origin policy helps out of
course but if we take it outside the
browser we need to do different things
and it was not supposed to break the web
I believe it's the case but of course
with browsers and everything that's
happening compatibility needs to be
guaranteed right because if it breaks
the internet then people are not using
your browser anymore at least that's
what we've seen with all the browser was
but um backwards compatibility is also
really important
so as I said it is a binary instruction
format for stack-based virtual machine
which is like similar s.net msio right
the CLR runs msil uh it needs to be a
portable compilation Target and one of
the additional security models they have
is we want to protect users from buggy
or malicious code
and we want to provide developers also
with helpful Primitives and what they
mean by that is
it should be pretty intuitive to take
the right path and if you need to do
something bad then hopefully the API is
really explicit or the compiler maybe
even tell it to you say like hey what
you're doing here it might be a risk or
consider not doing this because it might
be harmful I think that's the default
path should be straightforward easy to
use and secure
so a lot of design aspects but what
makes webassembly secure so each module
within the webassembly ecosystem
has got a piece of memory webassembly
memory and it's isolated per module that
gets loaded right so it's a chunk of
it's like an array of data
and it will be used only by that module
and if data needs to be shared across
other modules then you need to do
something for it so by default it's just
an array of bytes and the module can
manipulate that
a module itself of course might have got
security issues which allow you to
mingle with that memory so there's still
a possible way of of doing stuff that
might be unintended
so on top of having this kind of linear
memory there's an additional security
aspect of webassembly which we need to
be aware of and that's something called
control flow integrity
and I was thinking about this when I was
creating this presentation like how can
I explain this in the best way because
there are some really good articles that
go deep into how back-end compilers deal
with this but let's say this is a code
snippet that we see over here and what
control flow means is like what are The
Logical paths within my code that my
code can follow right so in this case we
see that we read a a read line from
console that gives input somebody types
in a string with screw but if somebody
types in a number we can say okay this
is the number that you put in and then
we're going to have two conditions
saying okay if number is greater than
five put it down the console right line
and saying it's larger than five
otherwise let's say it's smaller and
then we're done
so this is a a an execution and if we
translate this to a graph it may look
something like this right so we have the
first part that executes that we'll
always execute
taking the number writing it out and
then we get up at the decision saying
like hey if number is greater than 5
we're going to take this Branch
otherwise we're going to take the other
one so what control flow Integrity does
it has a map of these kinds of
executions within your app and it will
instrument your application and if at
runtime something occurs that breaks
that path then it will panic and it will
stop right so that should mitigate
that's the right word I need to use some
of the problems you might have if a
module mingles with its own memory so we
can safely say it's pretty secure how it
works in this way so it's mostly
compiler stuff that helps us out
so this makes webassembly in let's say
from technical perspective how it works
pretty secure how the instructions are
being processed during runtime and so on
one really cool project that leverages
webassembly is something called the real
box
who in this room is familiar with what
NL box is or has seen it before my it's
it belongs to Firefox
it's a Firefox team that created it so
when running a browser you rely on a lot
of plugins that take care of Media stuff
that gets rendered phones that gets
rendered and what the team with at
Firefox did together when I think with
the university is that they looked into
a way of taking those libraries
compiling them into webassembly so
taking C code probably am scripting to
convert them to webassembly
and then
you have some guarantees that the things
that I just explained to you so if
there's like some unmanaged uh let's say
overflow that kind of thing like the
basic security problems that would have
been taken care of by the webassembly
stuff itself so if you would then run
that plugin inside the browser it will
be safer but the only thing that they
didn't want is they didn't want to have
webassembly embedded inside the browser
it probably was high performance or it
was good enough but then they decided to
take that webassembly and translate it
back to C code and then put it in the
code base and then compile it all at
once which means that you take some of
the security
aspects you get from webassembly and
then put it inside the browser and the
other thing and the additional thing
that they did is they also created a
programming model that if you do this
with a plugin you need to when you're
writing the software you need to
explicitly validate the data that comes
back from the plugin so it's like a
helping out the developer saying like
hey you run this plugin data comes back
you need to have a validation routine in
order to take care of the data before
you process it and I think that's a
pretty strong model I'm not sure if
people were in my talk last year on
sandboxing.net some of the aspects this
this is the ultimate concept that I want
to implement on that same area because I
think this is quite powerful if you can
like help out developers doing a better
job
and next week I will be in NDC London
talking about that and once the video is
there and you're interested in it in
combination with.net look into that one
but at our box right as I said because
webassembly
in its way how it works is pretty secure
they use that they leverage that in
order to get it into the browser so
that's I think it's pretty cool
there's one really I think even two
really good talks done at blackhead on
this from the people who created this
you should watch that
so getting back to what if we what do we
need to do in order to get.net running
on top of webassembly so this is a
conceptual picture that I took from
uh from a guy called item Ivan Tolson
who is with fermion he works on spin so
um look him up but he did a talk on.net
and webassembly as well and he created
like this picture where you see like hey
if we have a.net application it consists
of user code which is il we have a base
class library that we use we have an
execution engine which they call vest
which will be the CLR that starts yell
out right so if you start out a process
the CLR would take care of
bootstrapping and stuff it will start
out and then it will run your app and
that of course all runs on top of your
host
and how can we run webassembly on top of
or how can we run.net on top of
webassembly
we can replace the execution Engine with
one that's based on webassembly so um
and of course we need to run it inside
the browser right and while we have
we've seen this concept of course that's
with blazer webassembly so what I've
done is they've taken parts of the mono
runtime which you see compiled into
version with M scripting there's a lot
of other things included as well there
is a JavaScript bridge that takes care
of some of the mingling because you need
to interact with the browser you need to
have access to the Dom and so on
but that was in itself will have the
framework and there are dlls right so
this is the basic the basic thing
let us quickly create a project
to see what type of things we get
streamed in order to fully understand
right so
let me do this first let me create a
quick Blazer app
say.net run
starting it out right so it's just
default template nothing fancy I want to
make sure that I have this one running
let's clear it all out
good to me
so now if we open up
you will see this is the default
template that gets executed
and if we then go to the thing that we
see over here which is
Network which view am I watching right
now not the right one I guess
let's let's do this once more
so
um
of course what happens is that the
browser will start downloading the basic
stuff of webassembly so it will download
first all the dlls
let me do it once more
because I might might have been some
caching right involved
did I stop the other one hold on a
second I probably did not do that
and it did not have the tools open okay
cool so if you have run this before and
I'm just going to skip this for now
because I'm just going to like go back
and forth within the screens but you
will see that it will first download all
the dlls right the.net application at
the end it will have.net wasm which is
the CLR implementation and then it will
start the.net application it will run
those dlls inside of the browser
so the other thing it's um
of course there's a performance penalty
right if you look into uh it's it's kind
of inter interpreted right because it
runs it runs a virtual machine inside of
a virtual machine that's that's at least
the quickest way they did do some
optimizations with the last.net release
um some people were expecting that the
full.net stuff would be emitted into
webassembly that aside from the fact
that it increases the size really big
it's not performant because some
features are not implemented into
webassembly like garbage collection and
so on right so there are some
difficulties but this allows us to have
us CLR that runs dlls inside the browser
and the JavaScript files will help out
doing some interactions with your system
so keep that in mind because that's the
first concept on how to run.net because
what do we need to do
if we want to take this outside the
browser
so we we still have a need for a
host where we can run on which in this
case is not the browser but the machine
and we want to have the execution engine
still run webassembly and what do we
need in order to do this and that's
something called
Wazi or webassembly system interface
right so in order for us to interact
with the system that's not the browser
we need to have some kind of abstraction
available and the nice thing about it is
that it's um
it's taking care of all the basic stuff
that we need
and it will make sure that it's a posix
inspired engine independent non-web
system oriented API for webassembly
and the other thing is that it was it
was introduced in 2019 by byte code
Alliance or bytecode Alliance isn't
Cooperative thing between big companies
like Microsoft firstly
they all help out they created this
standard to say okay if we have
webassembly running on this and we want
to interact with system like files
sockets everything we need standard
inputs standard output it will look
something like this and they also said
okay we're going to do runtime which is
like responsible for running the web
assembly because it wasn't time in order
to be guiding us through like as a
reference implementation
um
so it's a strong sandbox with
capabilities based security so we're
going to dig into it a bit further but
if you have the whole system model of
things you can access and if you can
then flag access and say like you're not
allowed to do this or you're not you're
not allowed to do that that can be
pretty granular pretty strong right so
um a.net application will start out in
its own process if you started on your
machine and it will have access to all
this things the same process as access
to and this is like an additional layer
on top of it it will give us more
control right so it will say like hey
are you allowed to write these files or
read these files
and there also will be future support
for sockets
for other things like um like sockets a
random like system other system access
that that needs to be like it's it's in
the making right now I will get to that
at the end of the presentation and it's
almost similar like to net standard
right we have all if you've been active
in.net at some point we had to converge
from.net core and the full framework
that standard was introduced to make
sure that those two bcl's got together
this in some way is familiar so
how strong is this wazzy concept in
general if you look at it for in
combination with webassembly
it's as good as
this guy tells Solomon hikes so he was
the founder of Docker and when was he
was first talked about
he mentioned in a tweet like hey it
wasn't you existed in 2008 there would
have been no need to create docker
which of course is quite a big statement
to make if you're the person that
started out Docker
um
but
it says it's the future future
next day after he's done this tweet he
came back he says like so will wasn't
replace doc he probably got something
with your phone calls or people pinching
him or I haven't seen the full thread on
Twitter itself but um
he says like no but it cannot replace
but it can be a good addition right
and uh it might be something that lives
next to each other like side by side and
what have we've seen over let's say I
think it was fall October of last year
is that they introduced docker's
capability of running wasm wasm assembly
um modules and in this case it uses wasm
Edge as you see on the right hand side
to execute the modules the things we're
going to do are all focus on on wasn't
time but wasn't Edge it's just a run
time that allows you to run webassembly
that is aware of wedgie as a whole and
they can execute stuff so
this is pretty cool so if we want to run
webassembly outside the browser we need
to have this
we need to replace the host with awazi
capable interface and in this case in
our case it will be where's on time so
we're able to run it and I think it was
built last year when Steve Sanderson
introduced
a conceptual experimental was the
sdk4.net that he created which will take
your app which will create a single
resume file that will use system
interface the y z SI and it will execute
so
let's go to an app
and let's see what is it right so keep
in mind that we saw that Blazer did
download everything
and now we're going to move to a console
app and we're going to fiddle around a
bit how it works and then also look into
um
um some of the capabilities we're able
to limit console as he yeah that's the
one
so it's it's minimal
um it's a console app signal line
contains a write out which is like hey
this is the OS architecture that you run
on top of you probably have seen the
same demo with Steve if you look into it
what do we need to do in order to get
this running on where actually we need
to make sure we have YZ SDK included and
this is a preview I think it was
released or published two weeks ago so
keep in mind all of these bits are
preview and I was wrapping up and making
sure I started it out and on Monday I
pulled everything in looks that it was
still working so that's cool but it's in
it's broke in progress which is a good
thing and a bad thing we will get there
as well at the end but this is the thing
so if we now say we built this
and if we then go to bin debug
five and look what we see here
I mind that I'd Fallen no hold on
this is the right folder so what we see
here
we see a console app.org if we just say
like okay this is the default executable
we get that will run on my Mac
if I run it it will say like hey
hopefully you can see it it's at the
bottom
maybe screw scrolling up a bit but
we see that it says like hey welcome
from arm 64 right let me do an increase
what if we take the the wasn't one
we will see exactly the same and it will
say okay now you're running in a wasm
context right so it's not running
directly on my machine but it's running
on my uh on my version time so even if
you have this SDK installed you can say
net run in your main project
and it will also doasm and it will sound
like okay what's Happening Here
underneath the hood it will start well
sometime and it's only tied to Western
time to execute but it will do exactly
the same so this is this is the thing
we've seen that there are different
architectures and also to I said
something about size right
um
if we do an LL here we will see
that we see console itself which is an
app pretty minimal one 145k probably
relies on some shell stuff that's on my
system right this one
is 8.5 Max but the problem is is that it
will do exactly the same as we saw with
blazer that was the reason why I showed
you that example at the beginning it
will put in all the dlls embedded there
is a awesome file that will bootstrap
the CLR and that will then start out the
app right so that's the difference and
that will be run on top of our assembly
so keep that in mind
so that's how it works internally
so what are the cool things that we can
do let's say
let's open up the file now we're going
to do some code let's say I want to open
a file
in webassemer let's say and it will just
be simple so let's say I want to read
the content of a file
which in my case will be file
potato texts
we don't text and then say we're going
to read
hosts file
and then I'm gonna just easily say right
line
content we're just going to take the
content of that file which is my Etc
host which is in my system
and then have it right out right so
net build
if I'm in the right folder hold on
so it is built so what if I now do the
the default app so this is my arm six
one right it runs on my machine you will
see the file
if I say net run
in this folder it will do the Western
time equivalent right what will happen
then
it will give a really obnoxious big
error but what it tried to do is it
tried to open a file that it was not
allowed to open
and that's the whole like as I said Wazi
capabilities type of thing and why some
time right now puts out this error there
are some implementations on other
runtimes that are more descriptive but
it will show us that we're not allowed
to do it and in order to get there
we need to instruct
the following thing so I'm going to say
to why sometime the directory you're
allowed to read
sure hoping that you're able to see it
and I already executed it but directly
you're allowed to read you just give it
the folder and pre-open the directory
and you will hand over the handle to the
wisdom time it's like you're allowed to
read it
and that's exactly what happens then and
if we then open it we say like hey we've
run this in the webassembly context and
we were allowed to open the file right
so this shows us the wesi capability a
file system and because we instructed
our runtime that it's allowed to read
files from that other location we can do
it by default it's not possible I think
that's good right talking about having a
good default and then explicitly
granting access to stuff that works out
as I said it's still under off are you
going to use it probably not but let me
get back to the slides because there's
more to that
it was experimental that's also what
Steve Sanderson says in this demo like
there's no guarantee we're going to do
this
um I think Wesley has a really good like
path forward so I'm I'm expecting that
they will do something about this and I
was talking to some of the people in
October and they pointed me out to this
issue which was created by Steve
Sanderson after he created this demo
what is that like Hey we're going to
support some wesi and some of the fixes
some of the bug fixes for the for the
SDK has been made and have been made
available already and I'm looking
forward to forward to the first preview
of.net 8 what this uh probably will
become better or will improve still no
guarantee that they will do it or if
they will release it but at least some
they're working on it and that's nice
right so this allows us to run.net on
top of webassembly outside the browser
with the help of lesson time or any
other wesi compliant runtime right I
think that's pretty cool and we're
allowed to limit file access and so on
now we need to get more advanced and
I want to move forward in moving to hey
what can we do in order to
extend.network webassembly
and with the whole wasn't time runtime
there's also wasn't time.net a new get
package that will allow us to run
version on top of.net
and it allows you to run
uh
like it allows you to to run any let's
say arbitrary webassembly module
the only constraint it has it needs to
be compiled against the the Wazi stuff
but you can write it in brushed you can
write it in Python you can write it in
go and that's exactly what I did so
let's move on let's go back we're going
to quickly peek into some Rust code
which is the module that we're going to
use the web assembly module that we're
going to pull into.net and then we're
going to run
I'm going to open up this one
collapse it make sure that we're in so
I'm not going to get a crash course rust
which is not the case but um
so where some time itself is also really
interesting and um
the language itself I'm really a fan of
it I'm working with it a lot lately this
is of course just a demo I took which
was already there but what it does
internally this stairs like it almost
looks like a console app within.net
right there's a main that will accept
arguments from the command line the
arguments are going to be passed on and
then it will say okay let's do the
process of those arguments and what it
does internally in this it will take one
file from source to destination it will
copy so we're going to mingle with files
again right including with Verizon time
but now we're also going to include this
inside of a.net application so
it's pretty straightforward nothing
fancy here it will it will build we can
do that right now
you can say cargo build
it's instantly done because there's
cache the file is already written so
it's there that's good now let's move to
the console app because there's a bit
more I need to explain in that one as
well
so as I said in order to execute
webassembly we need to have the runtime
available and that will be the package
and you could just easily do the Western
time package and edit
and washing time itself was released on
zero they quickly uh like they quickly
released a couple of other releases on
top of it but it's it's definitely
something you could start using if we
look into the program itself then we see
there's a lot of stuff happening
first we need to
instruct our runtime what we are allowed
to do and I'm gonna just redirect some
of the error some of the output to files
in order to see it because it's going to
be a separate thing that runs right I
need to pass on some arguments and then
at the end the passing arcs I'm doing
those are the arguments I will pass on
to the rust module to execute right
because I want to copy file a to file
position B
then we need to do a bit more about we
need to have an engine that will run the
webassembly itself there's a link that
will take care of the type resolving and
where stuff originates from and then
there's a store that will be used to run
and get the data in and everything
that's available we're saying okay we
want to run an awazi configuration we're
loading the wasm module from file we're
gonna instantiate it then we get a
function back and then we can invoke it
which is a lot of code yes I know
um but this is the basic concept and the
future of this you're going to see later
on how this will work but the nice thing
about this is that if we run this
let me make sure I'm in the right folder
so if I say.net run
we will see Hello indices security
nothing happened okay if we look into
the error log that's been written out
we will see that the rust module this
was one of the arguments we saw in the
rush module says like hey you want to do
this and you want to do a copy from two
but you didn't provide any arguments
that's exactly what we did right so that
kind of works so now say dotnet run
let's say we want to do a to c host
again the same file and we want to copy
it locally and say it's host
it's still for Bose
if we look into the error log again
we will see that it complains about the
fact that it cannot it cannot open
ATC host because it's not a pre-opened
file descriptor right so this is the
exact same things that we saw before
when we were doing the Western time
console but now it's it's
programmatically done so we need to
instruct
and it's allowed to read files
and this is exactly like the whole I I
want to make sure that if it opens the
directory and you can even map stuff so
let's say we're doing a map from Etc to
Etc same same way let's get rid of the
trailing slash I've never done that
probably it will screw up and then
um
that's a default one but we also need to
Grant access to the local folder
otherwise it's not alright
it has no right to uh to write the files
to our system as well so as I said it's
pretty explicit right you say like I'm
not sure how I want to be bought it but
if you look into the whole component
model which we're going to talk about
later you will see that it will fit in
and you will have descriptive stuff
happening so right now we have changed
it we say like okay you're allowed to
read from Etc and you're also allowed to
read and write from both electrics right
so
let's move back let's say dotnet builds
and now do the.net run again
and if all goes well which happened we
see that over here
that is a host file that's being written
and it's been copied to this local
system right so this gives us again
access to what type of files is this
module what type of parts of my file
system is this module allowed to access
and you can also reroute and say Hey I
want to say this is ETC but it will be
your subfolder of my current running
folder right so it's almost like a
container that isolates stuff and so on
so pretty powerful let's go
this is only related to file system what
else could be wrong with a module right
and get back to the first slide where we
talked about designing of webassembly
they want to safeguard end users also
for malicious modules so what happens if
a module is hacked or a supply chain is
compromised which is a totally different
topic of course but it does a lot of
compute
what else can you do in order to control
the amount of compute that a module can
execute
within webassembly and within uh there
is a concept called fuel
and each step within the engine will
take one Fuel and it's just like it's
not that it's tied to a specific amount
of Cycles it's just a logical unit that
they use so in order to do something at
the end you can say okay this will take
10 000 fuel
and if it exceeds 10 000 then we might
be better off stopping the thing and
that's exactly what you also get well
right now within the module so we need
to instruct the engine that we're going
to deal with this based on fuel
consumption and we need to make sure
that once we turn it on this is the
budget that you get and it's as
conceptual even the host can decide to
consume fuel if it fuels the need so you
can even have a dynamic system saying
like hey I know that this module will
take up this amount of ticks in order to
like fuel in order to complete I have
more control of it and that makes
um
that makes it
less prone to let's say a module that
has become malicious and that does a lot
of things maybe somebody decided to
install a crypto Miner and is doing
stuff with that on your machine it takes
a long time so let's just quickly delete
this file
move the trash let's move
and let's say a.net build again
did I save it
close it just to be sure I'm gonna build
again
if you run it right now you will see to
the end I I added an additional console
ride line which is like the best way of
programming right control right lines
but it will show us the amount of
consumed fuel which is in this case is
35 000. so let's say after a couple of
runs and you know a module should be
able to complete its stuff within that
amount let's say we're limited to twenty
thousand
let's say to 5000.
what will then happen if we build
again
save data close I'm just going to be
neurotic because
of the demo gods and then say dot net
what we did before
it will
it will give us a cryptic method saying
like hey it ran into a trap and this is
the Trap is the way of the wasm runtime
saying I'm stopping this execution
because it takes too long
um so that's a that's a way of view of
limiting what a module is allowed to do
so that will give you more control over
what it's allowed to access and also the
amount of things it can do based on that
fuel right so I think this is a pretty
powerful concept
and yes code is a lot of things you need
to do yourself but we'll get there at
some point I will explain what will be
the next PATH forward
so
we've done all of this and let's say we
have a wazzy module that we have
compiled
against uh um with c-sharp or rust or
anything else one other cool thing we
can also do with it is something called
thrusted computing
and trusted Computing can be based on
the following trap model
um this is one from x x k CD you
probably know this Jimmy drop tables
there's one on Supply chains like the
one with the big pile of rocks and the
one in the bottom which maintained by a
single person but this one explains like
what type of layers do you have inside
your modern stack deck that might be
compromised by a customer compromised by
Bitcoin miners compromised by your
government and so on right you can just
like literally say hey every layer can
be compromised and the cool thing about
it is that there is a project called an
ox which is started out by a couple of
people who came from Red Hat
it's a company called proof proofian
also part of bytecode Alliance and they
decided to take confidential Computing
with webassembly
um
and what they do is they take so-called
teas which are trusted execution
environments that's a part of your of
your CPU
and it's not a TPM it's different but it
allows you to take a Wazi based module
which we have seen we can write in.net
we can write in Rust we can write in
everything and we can run it in a
trusted way because what anarchs does
it will have the following threat model
it says like hey I don't trust the host
it runs on I don't trust the host owner
I don't trust the host operator
I want to make sure that the hardware
I'm running on is cryptographically
verified
and I want to make sure that software is
audited and and before it starts and
cryptographically verified as well so
can you imagine that you have
confidential data of let's say customer
or crypto let's say or something that
needs to do compute in the cloud
if you do it on Azure AWS Google you
rely a lot on their hypervices and
everything that's underneath that right
but you might not want that data to be
visible on that system
and this might be a way of dealing with
that so
what NX does it takes the T of your
processor which in AMD is the sav and
Intel SDS JX which is all acronyms and
then IBM has the pef but it will do
um
all the other stations that are
mentioned so once it start out it will
check the crypto of the processor it
will check its origin right there's a
root of trust in the hardware
and then it will have instrumentation
saying like Okay if I'm starting out nrx
itself I have a runtime that's
responsible for encrypting the workload
and pushing it onto the processor and
that runtime is open source everybody
can see it it can all can be audited and
the other thing that they do is they
also do
um at the station of that like how long
does it take normally to start out so
those are all indicators and if it's all
green then it will decide to run right
so that will all reduce the uh the risks
that you're facing if you're running
stuff on Cloud for example
um
I can also run this on my system and ask
itself but what happens then underneath
it will just take away some time and run
it right because that's in essence what
you're doing only if you're running this
on NX on a system itself on a hardware
it will be done on this plot right where
wazzy will run on on top of the wesm
runtime of anarchs and it will eliminate
that right so this is pretty cool so I'm
not going to bother you with
anarchsm and run it again because that
will be exactly the same but I think
this is cool because this shows that
wazzy has a good future and
um allows us to compile every language
we just use and have trusted Computing
so I'm expecting a lot of this of
anarchs so keep an eye out on that so I
showed you a couple of things and I
showed you code which was pretty let's
say verbose and on the stuff you need to
do all the errors you get like how can
you make sense of it so what's next for
wasn't what do we need in order to be
successful with this concept and there
are probably also stuff that we know
from the past which is an analog to this
and why would this succeed and why some
of the others failed we will get there
but
so the cartoons you see over here are so
called code cartoons that are created by
Lynn Clark who used to work for Mozilla
right now she's with fastly she still
does a lot of work for bytecode Alliance
and she's a really some really good
cartoon series on how to explain stuff
and she also has some of the things on
webassembly so if we look at the code
base itself right now if we write our
software 80 is other people's code right
that's a statistic that we also once
have Sun seen with our within our
reports that we create
so we rely a lot on others right and if
we look at dependencies
keep in mind like let's say this is some
application that starts the the top one
is the one that's responsible let's say
it's a.net process that has different
modules underneath then
the top one has access to everything
right system resources and it will pass
on the keys just to the lower part so
like hey if you want to have access to
this you can do it if you want to have
access to that yeah that's fine right
somebody else's dependencies can just
reach that right away
what happens if a module becomes
malicious right whereas a mask it has
become malicious it says okay let's take
a peek at your file system
it can still do it right in this context
because there's no safeguarding of not
allowing it to do right
what if there is a vulnerability in the
module that's the side person that talks
to the module and says like hey could
you just give me more system information
or whatever right so because it's all
the same context it has access to the
same resources they all have the same
keys this is a problem what can we do to
safeguard this
we could do process isolation
so if you look at let's say browsers
Firefox Chrome each Tab and there's
probably some more detailed information
on this but I think each tap mostly has
its own process of rendering right
because they want to have isolation you
don't want stuff to talk to each other
and in order to communicate between
process a and process B you need
something like an inter-process
communication or a process boundary IPC
call that's exactly the pipeline you see
underneath but if there is two process
the biggest benefit is that memory is
isolated as it says but there is a lot
of heavy weight around it because you
need to start on two processes
and it would have been better if we are
more minimal right so there's the big
process with two modules slower
communication a lot more overhead and
the the disclaimer at the bottom says
this is not drawn to scale just to
illustrate and the one at the bottom
there's like something called Web
assembly nanoprocess and that's the next
thing we're going to talk about so it's
much more minimal it's memory each
module has its own memory in order to
execute so what can we do to be more
successful in this
the memory the the
nanoprocess itself allows you to sandbox
right so if there's a module loaded
there's somebody who's in charge with
the head that will say okay this module
is allowed to that formulas we have some
before like you you can access this
folder or you can do this call on the
system get random right or it it can
access the clock or it can do the USB
make Pad there's different ways of
dealing with this but there's somebody
in charge that's on top of this
what else is more
um
it's important each of the memory
sections that belong to a module will be
limited as well so this module cannot
access the rest of the memory
unless it gets help of somebody else and
that's where interface types come in
right so you need to describe how data
looks and then module one can ask hey I
would like to have access to this piece
of memory can you give it to me and
there's somebody else that will then
take care of it right so modules itself
cannot access memory on their own they
probably can with the help of but it's
not their decision to make and that's
the process of interfacing types but
because you still want them there is
data that might needs to be exchanged
right between those two modules in order
to do something that totally makes sense
but you don't want them to have direct
access
and on top of that
we want to have an API with fine-grade
permission model title right so
the webassembly system interface with
descriptive stuff title it's saying like
you're allowed to do this
you're allowed to access this folder
you're allowed to do this socket you're
allowed to reach out to that one
that will then eventually become the
webassembly nanoprocess
so
and what they envisioned in this concept
is there is a main module that will be
in charge of everything and that will
hand out all the things and it will help
out
and it will eliminate if a module
becomes malicious and wants to have more
access it doesn't have it right it
doesn't it doesn't get it because uh the
ride is not there and that helps out so
I think this is pretty pretty cool and
how far is it so last year I think it
was October November there was uh Cloud
native Wesson day
um in in the US and there's a real good
presentation about the component model
which is the whole ecosystem I just
described to you done by Luke Wagner
you used to work for Firefox use but
fastly you can really see the trends
what the people were doing
um they are working on whole component
model on how the security model should
look at and how you then also need to
have tools in order to do stuff right
because that's also the thing you're
missing you're not going to glue stuff
together with code as I just did right
it needs to be more automated but this
is a real good presentation if you want
to see it on what's the path forward and
he's also a person that was involved
with the initial standards of
webassembly right so he really knows
what he's talking about and there's
definitely some really cool talks that
there wasn't there if you want to see
more
looking back at.net you probably would
say like I know we've seen this before
decom
yes but the first thing that Luke says
during his presentation is like it looks
like dcom yeah but we're not doing any
distributed stuff it's it's more mostly
next to each other close to each other
and if people want to do distributed
things with this it's a relying on the
runtime on the host where it executes in
right so that's not the responsibility
and the whole capability based model
we've seen it with codex security which
is like I have this book Like A thick
one when I started off my Development
Career there's so much complexity in in
what you could do with codex security
I'm not sure if any of you used it
medium trust in asp.net core at some
point we got that
um turned out just to be a mutex in user
space memory that you can flip in order
to turn it off right so it's really easy
to get around it and that's also the
reason why Microsoft this is not working
we're gonna limit it but this is
technically similar concept right and I
think um that's why
um I really I'm fond of this and I'm
keeping an eye out like how web assembly
and how the component model evolves
because it all relies on how the tooling
gets built
um and how it is so I see that I miss
out on one slide that was supposed to be
after this one so in order to do
better things with wasm and with the
interface type there's a tool called
white with buying gem which is also done
by Western time team and that's a tool
that allows you to generate all the
plumbing code you just saw me create
right so it will have the ability to see
the interface types and like this is a
module needs to have access to this
folders it needs to read create sockets
it needs to do access to random or to
other system resources that's the thing
you can then generate host Code 4 and
guest code and if you look into with by
gen itself you will find that there's
already demos fully working with rust
I think python is working as well
unfortunately not.net I hope that they
have the demo included but the tool
eventually will also support.net that I
think that's the goal right so the glue
will be there
um
but if we then recap and see all of this
and say like I know it's it's security
yes it looks kind of
um there's a lot of output but how
secure is it really
um
I think in general we need to make sure
that um
the whole system and how this evolves
depends on how secure the runtimes are
that execute this
and if you look at the stuff that was
published at blackhead and Defcon last
year in August every talk around
webassembly was about fuzzing runtimes
and about false today found in
implementations in runtime so that's
still applicable but let's just assume
that everybody does a real good job and
if you look at webassembly and why
sometime
they have a real cool blog post on the
bytecode alliance published in September
2022 where they explain how they
approach security within Western time
it's written in Rust so it uses control
for integrity as well right because
parts of the web assembly compiler stack
also has it it's it's based for the
clang which is a backend compiler and
they also have continuous fuzzing they
have formal verification of like does it
really do what it needs to do that kind
of thing and they have a whole process
around security and vulnerability
disclosure so they're pretty transparent
right in the open this is a Roku blog
post if you want to know more about how
it's being built but as I said the
disclaimer we need to be aware of is
it's a secure as it's runtime and then
it will stop
if we then look at um
the conclusion
I think if you look at Cloud native we
even saw serverless functions already
performed like webassembly payloads
right cloudflare does a lot of that as
well
I think it's here to stay and also with
Docker and web assembly modules it
becomes the next thing outside of it
it's minimal it's much smaller right it
has less to carry than a full Docker
container that contains it all
um so it has a lot of potential to be
used to run and extend your.net
application
as soon as the tooling gets in place
right because I think that's also what
you saw with codex security if the
complexity of that kind of thing is too
big and how could you even expect people
to expect it like to to use it in a good
way
and the thing that is key uh that's the
last bit
I like the whole top-down approach that
bad quote alliances taking right so
codex security was just there and it was
done to use and it was the big booklet
you need to look through they're just
working down examples on how you can
effectively use this and then they build
it up from there right so that's why the
demos might look a bit rough but they
said like hey if people start using this
and give us feedback then we can build
something that's valuable that's the
goal I think that's pretty cool
um and keep in mind webassembly runtime
is a Securities implementation so with
that said
I'm going to open up with enough time
left for questions so the first repo
contains the slides in the demos
um you can reach me on Mastodon on the
on the third link on my blog post I'm
going to say Tech thank you talk that's
the right pronunciation right talk
um hope you enjoy the conference hope to
see you maybe next time unless there are
questions I'm here until the end so
please feel free
to ask questions
and if not then I'm just gonna say I'll
let you go and say have a safe travels
back and hopefully see you next time
thank you
foreign